ragazzi non ci siamo suo happy meals
come potete vedere e mi mancano
effettivamente tre cose da fare in dieci
minuti di marca di botto ora non è che
sono forse la categoria che tra tutte
faccio di meno rahim postico sul trono
partire il timer 321 rischio partito 10
nuti stiamo dicendo tra le varie
categorie con infossi col rock swing
world trovo altro tua mamma trovo
qualsiasi cosa
sono troppo oltre e niente ho sbagliato
da rifare maledizione quanto voleva la
musica che se no non è un senso bene
diciamo tra tutte le categorie di
livelli minimi pozzi con rossi è quella
che faccio di menin assoluta il botto
run anche se effettivamente mary minchia
ragazzi non ne faccio anche uno in dieci
minuti ci sono morti in 30 secondi
porca vacca e si vede che quello che
faccio di meno perché quello dove sono
partito peggio tra tutti gli sci per
quello che sono partito page è molto di
più difficili quello che sembra bo torna
perché voi lo vedete basta andare dritto
no non è vero il botto run non è mai
così facile perché ogni bot torna alla
sua pendenza di bici vi spiego come un
tricheco morto per avete capito che
stavo dicendo l'abbiamo fatta e due
peccato per la partenza ma l'ultimo
premi sembra promettere bene già la
parco la partenza così potete battere
ragazzi ti basta non morire due volte al
primo proprio lui let's go ha preso il
via
ha preso il via quindi va dai non è
statica e pvc e cliccare che fare
livelli quale voglio almeno trenta
ragazzi votorantim 10 non è così facile
ve lo ripeto perché a vederlo della
madonna questo che botto rane porco
demonio non va solo io mi dove che
arezzo 4 incredibile attenzione
meno male perché stava morendo e molto
veloce come livello ma è molto più
efficienti quello che sembra dal video
non sembra per niente perché dai video
che hanno tutto pace ma affidate da
farne uno tra tutti i livelli in dieci
minuti questo è quel che teoricamente
promette meno bene perché quello che tra
tutti so fare di meno però forse se di
ore
molto bene molto bene molto bene mancano
8 minuti il lazio ragazzi let's go on
che partenza proprio lui li punisce
tutti parte 2
no madonna mi sono salvato scettica e
perfetto effetto effetto effetto siamo
poi se 10 madonna ecco quando una
persona deve chelsea dove si va a fare
un colloquio di lavoro il mio curriculum
sarebbe so fare i voti ho fatto un sacco
di bottoni in dieci minuti dopo e dai 10
ai ragazzi e molto ripetitiva come cosa
ma vi assicuro che per me che joe cole
non lo è perché è proprio difficile per
la pendenza giusta però è e liutai e
l'unico che posso sfruttare per fare un
record di quelli pazzeschi se non fosse
stato per i primi 30 secondi porco
demonio ma questo ha rifatto una cosa
pazzesca dottor lancia le giovani che
senza challenge dimesso più di 17 minuti
camon oggi sto battendo un record
infinito jump come faccio a saltare lo
sai che sei previsti non c'è il salto
vero vareremo a tornar non vale
ma non vale ci ha messo più cose dai
possono costretta a finirlo perchè l'ha
fatto così parco lemonia lanciato mio
figlio mi chiede cross kg ronaldo o che
lo stato mio figlio come ho fatto il
possibile e comunque suo livello è
impossibile perché ha messo altre robe
che non c'entrano assolutamente niente
non vale se uno tenta di farlo porco
demonio va bene va bene va bene un
piccolo intoppo quale va tutto bene
scream minuti e 36 vai
non ho mai capito se mio figlio mi aiuta
mi dà più peso teoricamente mi dà più
peso con gli effetti averlo porco
demonio dove vi lasciamo subito lo
lascio sempre ragazzi adesso perché è
importante avere meno peso possibile
sulla bici dio è veramente difficile
questo sto sbagliando un botto di volte
nonostante questo mi sembra lista di
star facendo un ponteggio abbastanza
buono ne pensate madonna che rischio non
è che nessun muri visibile alla fine
bike canoa sei minuti rimanenti vai
camon anno interessatamente quello che
ho detto io ormai sono il nostradamus di
f.liszt perfetto perfetto perfetto
perfetto vai vai
così i ragazzi sono andata bomba niente
male vorrei finire tutta la pagina si è
impossibile però sarebbe un sogno
perfetto no no porca vacca praga questo
impossibile
questo impossibile perché è fatto c'è il
turbo e veramente basso anno ce n'era
pd1 madonna perché poi devi calcolare il
fatto che se prendi un altro turbo male
tiziano sbagliato se prendi un altro
turbo di ti sbilanci quindi devi di
inventare prima mamma mia ragazzi quindi
difficile non me lo so spiegare con
luigi biancat che faccio ma ste figure
di kakà l'avrei tagliate bravo cava
perfetto master molto simile politica
non riesco a capire perchè io comunque
quando faccio il top 10 quando faccio i
top record in dieci minuti
io cerco sempre di mettere i livelli più
votati nella storia ok livelli più
votato in assoluto perché è così che i
bot ed eni time e poi fai più livelli
che riesce a far ok quello che ho fatto
anche adesso però ci sono alcuni livelli
tipo questo questo momento appena
facendo che come fanno sd più votato in
assoluto alla fine sono di rob seible
normalissimi invece ce ne sono alcuni
che abbiamo passato che sono dei bot ora
va a fatti dati da dio
quindi non lo so con una gamba sola
non devo perdere tempo sarei rimasta
fissa dello schermo anche per 15 secondi
buoni ma non posso permettermelo
perché se non perdo tempo madonna e
vinci o ma non me la torta ma non me la
dà perché non c'è non c'è non c'è la
vittoria va bene ma non avevo vinto però
io l'ho anche rifatto porco devono
infatti anche prima avevo vinto solo che
non l'hanno messa la vittoria allora non
vale
porca vacca quattro minuti tutto a posto
tutto a posto tutto a posto tranquilli
extreme madonna lega mi sto facendo un
mancano 4 minuti in tutto questo non so
quanto dovrebbe essere un buon punteggio
perché effettivamente non so quanto
siano veloci da fare il botto run sono
molto più tra tutti i suoi livelli più
lucida fare però devo fare anche in modo
che mio record rimanga quando batte un
record negativo
devi semplicemente fare un buon
punteggio devo fare una roba che sai che
poi non viene battuta facilmente visto
che poi mi spiegate sempre tutti
maledizione da devo fare figura di cacca
vedo che ci sono sacri livelli di jack
jack safety guy dio dio brando
ovviamente porca vacca vinto solo luke
io non ci voglio credere
3 minuti e 20 e faccio effettivo e di
merda non fosse agli anni passati a
giocare all happy meals camon perfetto
madonna voglio almeno il più record è
stato tipo 20
l'ho fatto 20 nero xing ho fatto 21
lismore trovo fatto 20
quindi se io batto 20 o già battuti i
miei record i dieci minuti però è vero e
tutto molto più veloce voluto run ma chi
se l'è inventato il botto orlando merita
un posto nel paradiso nella storia c'è
una rampa perfetto dovete 40k segway no
su segue sa cosa ho appena visto ragazzo
ho appena visto questo era un livello da
votare alto alto nel senso di votare
tanto perché questo era fatto bene era
diverso dagli altri ce ne sono stati
molto molto simili quindi non riesco a
capire
vai tranquillo qua devi fare un
impennata pazzesca ok questo a saperlo
l'avrei fatto giusto anche l'inizio però
non sai mai impegnato molto deve essere
quello di prima era veramente diverso
quello era da votare bene fighissimo
a queste si allungano
ti prego non ci credo ma per cosa sono
morto per un niente a dio santo dio bo
random ok dai forza
[Musica]
perfetto buono questo non ci credevo mai
da soli in carta anni me ne basta uno
dove mi incarto e ho perso ci ho perso è
poi non ne faccio bene anche uno ne
basta uno ai ragazzi porca vacca
potrebbe tranquillamente essere questo
viola figlio 6 inutile un minuto 27 ko
[Musica]
madonna questa era veramente difficile
non vi spiego quanto a tenere la
l'andamento non è stato prendete facile
116 sbattimento ti sei fatto per mettere
una bottiglia diversa dall'altra
no ho sbagliato questo è un web boltro
bis world aveva niente fa niente a
questo lo deve contare purtroppo già
sito peace words hanno più ward le
parole ho letto spade
pensavo fosse uno small trovo va bene 58
secondi dai cava un ragazzo che poi non
so se è praticamente alla fine riesce se
riesce qualcuno a battermi fino qua
madonna ho quasi finito la pagina ci
pensate voi come sto messo madonna come
rimorchio facile il suo sabato c'è il
prossimo sabato perché salvatore ieri
voglio morire porca vacca 30 secondi dai
non inkheart arti le voglio ancora due
no sono vivo perfetto culo anche questo
anche per stipendi per vivere
ti prego allora per un record
imbattibile dai finisci all'indietro
santo iddio 10 secondi va dai 8 secondi
ti prego è mica ce il type r col poco va
a fan azzorre dati avrei vinto in tempo
rivinto sullo scoccare dello zero porco
demonio
e invece no perché c'era la scelta del
personaggio cioè tu puoi mettere un
volto un vorranno un botto run con la
scelta del personaggio poi vabbè non lo
commentiamo rea pazzesco vai continuo
fatti 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 6 set 18 9 22
24 25 in 78 30 31 32 35 35 livelli in
dieci minuti
madonna o ragazzo tanti per l'amor di
dio però poteva andare molto meglio se
non fossimo all'inizio dai vi sfido
questo è veramente difficile rispetto a
tutti gli altri ho fatto provate dai
dati di battermi ovviamente nel caso
fatemi sapere che io poi fare una
riccione tutti coloro che mi batto
nostrani sia piaciuto ragazzi
iscrivetevi a che la spiaggia della
campanellina era come sempre ci vediamo
a non farselo video della ragazza
[Musica]